Bảo cao chính trị, bảo cao tổng kết 4.5 đổi mới, bảo cao tổng kết 4.5 thì ai nhiều lệ đang,
lực chuẩn bị kiế lưỡng và có nhiều đổi mới.
Lần đầu tiên, bảo cao chính trị được tích hợp theo một chục thống nhất,
đồng vộ ử một tiêu, nhận vụ đến giải pháp.
Tung tắc chuẩn bị trải quan nhiều vòng thảo luận có ý,
thế hiện tin thần cầu thị tin trù trong lãnh đạo của đang.
Một tháng qua, không khi có ý giễn ra sâu dồng thức chất trên mọi cân.
Một tháng, bảo cao tổng kết nội dùng của phần kết.
Nó cho thấy rằng, kết xưa mối sáng cạo là một,
nhưng mà nó thịt tin thần trách nhiệm,
có trình làm việc để làm sao đó.
Văn kiện trình trình cả con nhiều người dùng.
Tự cá khổ nhỉ, chung ơn, với chi thức cho đến kiểu bảo ở lào cáp buồn chia.
Hàng trở ý kiến đăng hoa thành dồng trải chỉ tuổi,
hướng về đại hội mối bốn.
Nếu ý kiến tánh giá cao tầm dình của phần kết.
Nếu thông đồng người nằm tại lào, rất là bui mời.
Nếu dự hoàn toàn nhất chỉ, văn bản sự kiện này,
thông đồng vũi tổng chữ mong trọng ngay là,
hơi đất lơ túng ta, ở đại hội thành công tất đẹp.
Năm sau đưa vỷ thế, Việt Nam đến phần trường cục thế.
Ngoi 2 mình đề, tôi đồng cóc, có lấy lời,
văn kiện đại hội đàn đó nó nên thích nhất.
Nếu để chúng ta, hãy đơn cào để bị chất lợp.
Chất lợp giọc.
Nếu chất lợp, chúng ta, thông qua, vẫn đề gì.
Là đăng tạo ra đệ cho vừa hậm.
Đi đối với hành để tạo ra những mình như lực mà nóng cóp ra xa hội.
Một đi mới rất đáng chú ý là tổ biên tập có báo cáo diên về mề tám nhóm vẫn đề cho yếu,
giúp cán mục đảng viên phản nhân dân,
nắm só trọng tâm để cóp ý, lũng và chúng.
Đi các hội nghị trụ ương đến hội thảo của dưới chi tức.
Từ phòng họp cơ quan đến dễn đàn trực tuyến,
không khi cóp ý sự thảo văn kiện đại hội mùi bốn từ sự làm thoảng mẹ.
Hành trởi kiến tâm vết của các nhà qua học, chuyên gia,
đảng viên lạo thành, xoanh nhân và người dân cùng đồng thuận với sự thảo.
Một cóp ý không còn là đống cóp cho đảng mà là cóp phần kiến tạo dương lai của chính mình của đất nước mình.
Và khi ý đảng họa của lòng dân, khi văn kiện là sản phẩm của hàng trở trái tiêm vào khuối ác,
đó chính là rất mạnh để đất nước mình, cất cán.